on today Pride celebrations happen all
over the country including right here in
Las Vegas Saturday is a celebration it's
kicking off at Elevate pool that's in
the Sahara hotel and casino and that's
where we have Candace Charles live this
morning with how this is just the
beginning of a long list of community
and even family events Candy's already
got your moves going on I can see it
yes we will be splish splashing around
at the Elevate pool party here at Red
show at the Tire Las Vegas good morning
YouTube good morning folks this is the
huge kickoff for the pride month lots of
events going on and I have the one and
only Joshua Hatfield with me thank you
so much for joining us tell us a little
bit about Pride what is it all about
so Las Vegas pride has been around for
about 40 years June is when pride month
is celebrated nationally so we have a
whole month of programming this June to
celebrate pride month as well as our
parade and festival and programming in
October amazing amazing and I know there
are Pride parades all over the place in
October L.A San Francisco New York Vegas
is doing it big this month in June as
well tell us about the events that are
going to be happening you guys have a
little bit of everything we do so we
have our signature event here at Sahara
Las Vegas the Elevate pool party that is
every Saturday and it's a ticketed event
but it comes with free parking and it's
really a pool party that's inclusive for
everyone everybody just to come out and
celebrate Pride that's our signature
event and then we have a family hike
monthly we have a family bingo we've got
our Las Vegas Pride magazine that
uplifts and celebrates the community
that way so we've got a lot going on I
love it I love it thank you so much
Jocelyn for chatting with me and getting
in the pool with me it's morning with
all the work you do in the community as
well it is going to be a red and a wild
month of events and you guys can find
all the details about it on our website
isnow.com for now live from Sarah Las
Vegas I'm Candace Charles jumping in the
pool eight news now
she's going for a dip there it is yeah I
don't blame you uh thanks Candace
appreciate that this weekend by the way
the lgbtq center of Southern Nevada is
hosting an enchanted forest youth prom
organizers wanting to create a safe
space for local teenagers and celebrate
a milestone they may miss because of
anxiety the event is free you have to
register first though this will be over
at the Palms Saturday night starting at
seven more details at the Center's
website thecenterlv.org